[Musique]
des tableaux précis et intimiste des
visages marqués par le temps des
portraits serrés ou les expressions ne
peuvent être ignorées une inspiration
pour françois bonnel je ne m'explique
pas exactement je crois que c'est
vraiment un travail sur votre peut-être
parce que le visage exprime renvoi
quelque chose qui a qui a qui touche à
l'universel et puis on retrouve dans
dans les regards dans les reflets dans
les yeux dans des expressions dans des
manières de regarder soit regardé
ailleurs ou au contraire de s'adresser
aux spectateurs il ya tout un tas de
choses qui peuvent justement à la fois
qui me touchent moi et qui peuvent
peut-être aussi toucher le spectateur
des oeuvres à connotation religieuse ou
le sentiment trans part et les amateurs
d'art auront peut être l'impression de
déjà vu françois bonnel s'inspire de
tableau datant des xviie et 19e siècles
ribera van dyck ou jordan ou presque
donc il s'agit en fait d'une d'une
démarche qui est à la fois je dirais la
ses documentaires puisque je suis très
très attaché au détail ont rendu
justement des effets que que l'on
retrouve dans ses tableaux en même temps
c'est un vrai travail d'interprétation
puisqu'il ne s'agit pas d'un simple
copier coller mais plutôt encore une
fois d'une d'une manière de revisiter
des oeuvres du passé qui me touche
particulièrement françois bonnel donne
une seconde vie pour ses tableaux un
nouveau regard qu'elles soient faites au
pastel ou crayons une cinquantaine
d'oeuvres est exposée
[Musique]